-(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
-Thank you very much. All right.
Please, we got an amazing show,
so shut up. (CHUCKLES)
MAN IN AUDIENCE: Love you, Bill!
I know, I love you too.
But, uh, there's a lot
to talk about today.
Congress is in chaos.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(LAUGHS)
No, it's not a repeat. I mean,
and that could be any show,
but you saw--
heard what happened?
The Speaker of the House
got shit-canned.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, APPLAUDS)
-This has never happened.
Yes, uh, Kevin McCarthy was--
he's from California.
He was the Speaker of the House,
Republicans got rid of him.
Well, actually, he made a deal
with the Democrats
to keep the government open.
Uh, and then they fired him.
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
This guy has more knives
in his back than Britney Spears.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
What? We just--
We make little jokes here.
No, but McCarthy's big sin,
of course,
was working with the Democrats
to keep the government open
which Republicans felt
was dangerously close
to governing.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But, you know,
he is second in line.
Do you know that?
The Speaker of the House.
-That's-- No biggie.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But that's how it works.
President, vice president,
check with Matt Gaetz.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-That's how our-- (CHUCKLES)
So... (CHUCKLES)
Okay, so now they're looking
for the new Speaker.
Uh, lot of Republicans
throwing their hat in the ring.
Jim Jordan,
do you know this guy?
Former wrestling coach.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The perfect preparation
for government work.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And also, famous
because he never wears a jacket.
-(CLICKS TONGUE) That's his--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(CHUCKLES)
Uh, Bob Menendez heard that,
he said,
"Where do you keep
your gold bars?" (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, APPLAUDS)
-Uh...
Well, we, I mean, we don't know
if it's gonna be him.
Republicans don't know
who they want.
They don't care
as long as they own the libs.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And the Democrats,
they don't care who it is
as long as it's a Black lesbian.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
Oh, we make little jokes,
please.
But, uh, no,
the really big story this week,
the substantial story,
is that even Biden now
is admitting
that the migrant crisis is real.
He said today,
"Fuck it, build the wall."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I mean, I-- I-- (CHUCKLES)
I thought I was getting punked.
I-- I--
Well, you know,
there's an election coming up
and he's gotta move
to the center.
It was either that
or shoot up a case of Bud Light.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Uh...
But a lot of the Democrats
actually feel betrayed by this
'cause it does go
against his campaign promises.
I mean, they said,
"We know it's in our platform
that it says
'secure the border,'
but we didn't think
you'd actually do something
-about it." (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)